[Music]
well dave ramsey doesn't know what he's
doing
i mean everybody uses debt that's
wealthy
no you must live in your mother's
basement and write that financial blog
because the actual data of wealthy
people is is that by and large they
don't use debt to get there by and large
they do get their homes paid off
the vast majority of america's
millionaires 93
of them did not inherit their money
according to an airtight piece of
research that the ramsey research team
did
and out of those 93 of america's
millionaires we studied over 10
000 of them the largest study ever done
the vast majority of them paid off their
homes early
and had money in their 401ks and in
their roth iras and mutual funds and
that's how they get their first
1 to 5 million now if you want a billion
instead of for the first five million if
you want to jump
try to straight jump straight to a
billion well you might borrow money out
your eyeballs
that's possible but i'm not here trying
to create billionaires i'm here trying
to create millionaires
because i want families to be able to
retire with dignity be able to change
their family tree and be able to live
well
i don't need you to go broke six times
in the process getting there we're not
trying to write a success manual
on going broke over and over again by
taking all this risk
i went broke once and i did all of i did
that apparently for all of you so you
don't have to
because you can learn from my stupidity
you don't have to follow it
so this i this this idea that
sophisticated people
all borrow money is absolute statistical
hogwash
it's simply not true they do not
now do sometimes billionaires yes
sometimes they do
do somebody worth 30 million dollars
maybe but you got 30 cents
30 cents and you're losing some of your
sense all the time
and so don't talk to me about how
sophisticated people borrow money you're
freaking broke
they do not now that's what i used to
think
because that's what my broke finance
professor taught me
if your finance professor is broke
that's like having a shop teacher with
missing fingers
you should think about where you're
getting your advice
so be careful when someone says oh well
such and such like
ramsay is not sophisticated the stuff we
teach is
unbelievably profound and sophisticated
it just doesn't line up with your get
rich quick little immature self and you
don't like it some of you
oh well you don't have to follow it
this is america you have the right to be
wrong
you're allowed to go do whatever you
want to do so she's brilliant she's done
a great job they've handled their money
beautifully
and they're well on their way to
substantial wealth
and we meet everyday millionaires baby
steps millionaires who follow these baby
steps by the tens of thousands
every day i meet more
and is it because i didn't make up any
of this i didn't invent any of this
it used to be called common sense
it's just now marketable because it's so
freaking rare
it's like having a superpower
i've made millions and millions of
dollars selling common sense
because there's not any out there and so
it turns out it's like a rare commodity
it's like finding a big old diamond out
in the middle of your backyard
look at that oh my god that's a genius
live on less than you make
who would have thought of that you know
but that's really that's where we live
instead we've got
oh i'm going to bitcoin my way in and
i'm going to play the lottery
and i'm going to borrow and do nothing
down real estate and buy 73 houses with
no money
and think that ain't gonna bite me in
the butt later
of course it's gonna bite you in the
butt later it's gonna take you to your
knees it did me and it will you
please don't do that stuff gonna bring
pain to your family and then you have to
do it all
over again it's much easier just to do
it slower and do it right
it's also faster to do it slower and do
it right
it's easier to do a job right the first
time and wealth building is no different
so walk these baby steps and in 10 to 12
years you'll probably be a millionaire
most of you
but to the extent you don't then you
have to wander off and find your own way
because you're going to reinvent common
sense
that's just silliness and that is not an
indicator that the stuff that the ramsey
personalities and dave ramsey teach is
simplistic
or out of touch or he's such a boomer
oh my god you're such a child
you're just such a baby child listen
little baby child
here's the deal the boomers got this
stuff figured out
that's how i lived this long got this
thinking much money
it didn't because i was stupid or
unsophisticated
or ignorant or backwoods or any of those
things
this stuff is profound it's easy to
understand but it is
life-changing because you have to change
your life to live like this
in the middle of a culture that's lost
its freaking mind